Oh, man.
Now, this may sound bizarre, but
It's the first time, I've seen all my cars in the UK. On the track
What a view!
Oh my lord! Jesus..
How nice, seeing all my baby's out for the day, together for the first time.
Amazing.
Amazing, amazing, amazing.
What a beauty.
Shall we try this one first?
Right, the first time all the beautiful cars are out for the day together.
Time to get sweaty, so if you would be kind enough to do me a favour,
and get out the fu***ing way.
This is my McLaren Senna. Only 500 of these beauties were made.
It's like driving as fast as a roller coaster you've ever been on.
Oh my god!
(You alright?)
Sh*t!
Oh my god, that is insane. No?
Oh my god, first time I want to sleep with a car.
Beautiful. Boom.
My Porsche 918. A 4.6 liter, V8 engine, with 2 electric motors.
This is no Prius. 0 to 60 in 2.5 seconds,
this spider has some bite.
This just gets better and better and better. Oh my god.
Now this is what I call a car.
Every time I sit in this incredible car,
It gives me chills.
With only 200 made on the planet,
LaFerrari Aperta is on a different level.
Nearly 100 break horse power
Fu*k me, it's fast.
Just when you thought the day couldn't get any better,
It just keeps on giving and giving and giving.
What an amazing day.
Some of the most amazing cars. My new, vintage,
And more importantly, some amazing friends and family.
And that, from a chefs point of view trust me
It doesn't get hotter than this
That, is a dream come true.